well let's move on now to the search for
solutions we were hearing earlier in the
show about the earthshop prize it is of
course prince william's campaign to find
solutions and innovation to tackle
climate change from across the world
around half of those finalists announced
today were from the global south well
what does that say about our search for
solutions and judy there's a real
simplicity to some of these um
shortlisted
solutions isn't there i mean costa rica
making micro payments to people to just
do their bit to protect a little bit of
rainforest
absolutely you know there are things
that only governments can do and that's
where all the protests and pressure
comes on but indeed there's some things
that individuals sections of society
like business nd
ngos and so on can do and they do it
well because they're in touch with very
local characteristics and cultural
dimensions you know take the case of 14
year old phoenicia she notices that in
her country millions of people still use
street ironing services and she's
created a solar powered ironing card in
a very sunny country to make a
difference it is amazing and you know
and i applaud prince william for saying
that he needs to be able to look his
children in the eye and say he did this
bit
you know as much as we live in a
science-dominated world it's still our
emotions and our commitment to family
that drives our strongest motivation to
act and to be fascinated inspired by
people that look like us
having amazing services it's important
to note though james isn't it that there
are no british shortlistes on that list
many of the ideas that were shortlisted
from from the global south are we a bit
arrogant in thinking that it's g7
western nations that really have the
answers here
um i think there's a risk of that i
think there's a risk of in in every part
of the world is that uh countries see
the climate crisis and the sort of the
clean tech revolution that will
hopefully help resolve it as these kind
of national local regional issues but
that's true everywhere and and one of
the most exciting things about some of
the stories we cover at business green
is the huge breadth of of innovation and
investment that we're seeing in all
parts of the world including very much
in these emerging markets and in the
developing world i mean there's one of
these talking points you get a lot from
people who are opposed to climate action
who say well what about china what about
india what about these big polluting
countries that are you know are
investing in coal yes they are but
they're also in china's case the world's
biggest renewables market the world's
biggest electric vehicle market and we
are seeing
some catalyzing progress from some of
these countries that are
in some ways because they don't have the
legacy high carbon infrastructure
they're able to leapfrog that and deploy
clean technologies at scale at pace uh
ahead of some industrialized nation so
it's much more simplistic than the idea
that the industrialized world is going
to solve this on its own and then kind
of through its largesse
help developing countries i think that
you know that is a borderline
neocolonialist way to see it necessity
is often the mother of invention isn't
it it's been really good to talk to you
both tonight judy linguang and james
murray thank you